Today I'm going to find out with curator
Selina Hurley, how a bed and a bicycle
led to the creation of the Paralympics.
I recognised Stoke Mandeville from the
Olympics, so I'm guessing I know what
this is, but do you want to tell me?
So basically what it is; it's a bed cycle
and it was developed at Stoke Mandeville Hospital
by someone called Ludwig Guttmann
who you can see his name just there.
And he developed ideas
that rehabilitation after an injury or
particularly after war injuries should
include physical and emotional [rehabilitation] and work.
So it's basically a bicycle turned on its side?
Yes. So it's made of lots of different bicycle parts.
We have the handles here, so you
would pedal with your hands here.
Or you would pedal with your feet as well.
There's actually a little speedometer here
so you can see how fast you are going.
And you can set how long you would be going for.
There's also a gear so you can actually change
the tension like you would on an exercise bike.
There's a lot of big, twisty, physical things on this.
So what did this turn into over time?
We know that this one was actually still
used until 1994 at The Chaseley Trust,
who donated it to the museum.
There's obviously lots of different
physio kind of exercises now,
and hydrotherapy as well, but you still have
forms of exercise bikes that you use today.
But you can just imagine what it
would be like to lie down either on this
bed, or have this rolled over your bed
for your daily exercise, whether you
wanted to do it or not.
And Stoke Mandeville went on to start the Paralympics is that right?
It did. So they used to hold
an annual games at Stoke Mandeville
which was developed by Ludwig Guttmann and his staff
and the eighth version of that games
turns into the first Paralympic Games.
So, we have a great object that tells some
really personal stories, but also has
this much bigger link to the Paralympic movement.